what up guys welcome to just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to
my ex still pays my bills a lot of you
guys requested this video so i'm about
to get right to it
um before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification
bell i'm trying to get to 20 000
subscribers each and every one of you
helps me get to that
goal um while you're at it
bring the notification bell you're going
to be notified of my daily videos
i don't have these you're watching this
video thinking that every man they meet
oh i love your apartment we gotta move
why because you [ __ ] here before
so i look at it in two ways so i
personally feel like that person has
taken me from one space
or level in my life to another so i'm
forever grateful and i also in the same
note feel like if i was to ever
be in the space that i could repay in
any way shape or form that i
would you know what i mean but um and
the other side of me is like you can't
take it back anyway so it doesn't matter
because you've already placed me at this
space
so it's like yeah unless you want me to
fake be with you
to keep my [ __ ] then let's just be
friends and it didn't work and that's
that but you gotta continue to you know
your credit is gonna messed up i don't
know
but he continued that he did continue
he's yeah he's still paying it yeah yeah
yeah it's been like i've been with my
guy maybe like going on one year
and he's been paying my i would love to
meet your guy i would really love to
meet him because
those men are weird i don't know
that another man
where are you meeting these guys oh my
god that's
that's simp behavior that is scent
behavior
everybody know everything every night
she's saying because she was in the
middle of the lease and she couldn't
afford it
that's why um
and that would like mess up his credit
that would make a little
sense not really but because can you get
out of a lease you should have just
bought her out of the lease
yeah but what was your question i'm
sorry my thing
is what what kind of money there's no
this is no judgment
i mean obviously he's okay with it my
man feels like let's while we have this
opportunity let's stack our bread
you know that's why you are together
that's what that is
like i was trying to come out because if
i was sneaky i would have stayed with
nobody
sneaking like you're crying what i'm
saying is your man is awesome like oh if
that [ __ ] gonna pay the rent
then we're gonna come up with him so
young man i think he's just i mean
he thinks that [ __ ] is a sucker yeah
yeah my man does think that i think he's
a sucker
he thinks that but i don't think that no
that's that's my friend
[Music]
brother
i have a son if my son was well off and
he decided to put a woman in a car i
would feel like that's disrespectful for
you to take you should have never put
that woman in that car
that's how i feel and i raised
is she saying it's because of like the
payments
that would make sense like obviously if
you buy a girl car
you have to keep up with the payments
but maybe you should just take the car
then like don't
keep paying for her to like or buy it
out
i don't know i've never had like that
lavish little lifestyle
in my car like from men
other than like my dad then he should
have thought of that in the budget
from day one when he initially got the
call you know what i mean because
brexit was hard by cheating remember i
said cheating
no cheating is different cheating is
different i feel like if someone cheats
on you
then yeah you should take the stuff away
because they're being sneaky they're
using you you know they're using you
but if you're open about things like i
was in this relationship where it just
wasn't working but
we remained friends and he was still
paying that during our friendship
and then maybe like five months later i
got with my guy
you know you're not going to stop i
think i never seen your man before and
and kind of was like why don't you just
pay this [ __ ] so you don't have to worry
about him like yeah
but he don't have i mean that's me
i mean neither have you either given me
an issue to where i had to feel
like that you know what i mean it's not
like that man has ever placed me in a
space
like the guy that pays my bills or pays
whatever he's never told me like yo you
got to figure this out do you see that
man
but when you see your man do you see him
as a provider
because he's not really providing for
you he does in every other way like
providing for me like what just our home
i mean like who like who's more
important to you right now
your boyfriend or the one that's paying
for your shelter they play different
roles in my life
no like my my man is my man like i'm
gonna put him above
anybody well i'm so what's for love and
one's for money i'm not with the other
person but respectfully right just
because we're not judging we're not
judging you at all
i'm just trying to understand the full
situation
why would he keep paying ideally yes
i've dated a guy
who was very wealthy when we separated
he was still paying the bills right
under the contingent and the
understanding that i'm not [ __ ] with
nobody else
so i hid that i was in another
relationship for a while
did i ever discuss with the other
significant other that this man was
still paying the bill
yes but you've never had a guy offered
pay my
rent maybe i'm just not hot enough for
this stuff i don't know
what happened eventually eventually he
said yo if you if you're going to be
with me 100
you're going to move out of that
apartment whatever attachment you have
with this man you got to wrap that up or
you're saying to me
that you're trying to have your cake and
eat it which is a bad analogy because if
it's my cake i can eat it right all of
it
but the thing about it is it's like
who's who's getting your
he still has a piece of you so now i
have to decide what kind of future i
want with this other man
is he just something to fly by night and
i'm having a good time because if that's
so
then i'm gonna have my cake and eat it
too i'm gonna keep this one paying my
bills which is lovely
and this other one doing whatever role
he plays but if i'm trying to take it to
the next level
then at some point even me moving into a
man's house and
see i'm trying not to be judgmental
because if i was offered free rent
from an ex would i take it
hell yeah like if i was offered it but
would i expect that hell no but who's
gonna turn down free rent like
that that is already there before i got
it you guys are sick we gotta get new
furniture
it's time to get a new mattress and
everything i don't want the mattress
you've been sleeping on
with the other my dad passed away right
and my mom moved on this is like super
personal and my mom moved on and it
caused
a strange relationship between the two
of us because how i found out she moved
on the man was staying in the house that
my father passed away in
he was sleeping in the bed that my
father had slept in for years
and so it caused so much hurt to me
because i said what man one still wants
to sleep in the bed that this man
was humping and dumping and they had
memories and [ __ ] i felt like
i would have respected him i can't
control who my mother moves on with i
can't change that dynamic
he'll never be my father but
respectfully i felt like
if he had any long-term
plans with my mom he would have said
listen
i can't sleep here tonight and i can't
move in this house we can get on
i mean all right i mean i don't know if
you got kids though you can't ask her to
move
all of her kids i was with you
not holiday yeah the man met your
beautiful mother
god bless both of them why why does a
man gotta buy a whole damn
if i meet a woman that has a beautiful
condo
that her man has bought her and i walk
in there
the last thought on my mind is like oh
[ __ ] she was getting [ __ ] in here
i got about a whole new condom i'm not
doing that
yeah that's what i was thinking anyone
people take free [ __ ]
sorry i ain't a real [ __ ] i'm gonna go
in and say damn
but it's like y'all put so much pressure
on men financially
it's like that's just too much pressure
so if i meet a girl
and she comes to my house right should
that girl feel like
well i'm [ __ ] you now guapo and this
bed has been used and abused probably
buy a new mattress that to me is like
girl i won't buy your hair it's very
entitled i would not expect
someone i was dating to buy me new like
if they want to i'm always appreciative
like when my boyfriend like buys me
stuff i'm always so appreciative i say
thank you whatever
but it's weird that they expect him to
pay the bills after
doing a bit where does he offer again if
you offer like
people aren't going to say no to free
[ __ ] for you i get you no that's
different
don't be putting that on no man and
don't have these girls watching this
video thinking that every man they meet
oh i love your apartment we gotta move
why because you [ __ ] here before
no i took it like that i took it like
you said that your mom's boyfriend maybe
your mom has to be at least 50. all
right so let's just say a 50 year old
man
should i have to buy a new house for his
new woman
you have a house you've been blessed
with a house i'm dating you
we're going to make this our house and
i'm gonna add to it
help with the bills and be a part of
your house but the man is no longer
listen hold on but the man that's no
longer living there isn't still paying
the rent there it's not paying the
mortgage there
isn't still contributing to that
household being a household while
another man is staying there
that's what i'm talking about well i'm
telling you though every man that meets
a woman that has a house
a home does not have to feel like i have
to upgrade the whole house
new she rocking i would imagine most
guys it's ideal that she moves in with
him
i think that's how most guys would
prefer it that's true
it should be listen i had a husband
before i met you
and he took care of me in this house as
my new man
come through and help do the same thing
but as far as him saying
a whole new house that's pressure that
men don't need
and don't worry about women i agree with
what you say i i don't
if a girl really loves you you're not
gonna have to replace her bed
house like everything she ever had just
to be with her
but i don't mean he has to put up all
the money to move us into a new place a
new space
what i mean is for example my man now
his apartment
already existed with him and he had one
with him and his baby moms at one point
he's like come stay with me i don't want
to stay there extra
whatever call it what you want i will
stay at my place and you stay at yours
and then when we find a place mutually
for us to live in together we get a
place together
it's not fully extra because i know i
you know i left my relationship
and i'm gonna be honest with you i will
not move a man in my place until i get
another place i don't want a man in that
bed with me
because that's my ex that's our
environment so i probably get new
furniture
if i'm going to move them in or go to
somewhere else because all the members
of my ex is in that
i would not care i would not care
apartment i'm cheap i'm not buying new
furniture if they want to buy it for me
cool but
i mean right now i live at home so it
doesn't matter i don't
have anything but you get you guys hear
what i'm saying i wouldn't feel
comfortable having
um my new man in that bed at all that's
why i got a joke
if my man had a mansion and i don't care
if he did the playboy
bunny lifestyle i'm moving in that [ __ ]
i don't care
tell me what happened
but i think y'all up here with big cat i
have a question
what if like i didn't say like the whole
story from the beginning but like
i was dating this person for like four
or five years and in the first two years
i supported myself but also helped them
build
their business and this like i dedicated
all my space and time and everything to
their personal business
and um i ended up getting them like a
fifty thousand dollars i ended up doing
like a whole bunch of things that set
them up
to be in the space where they were able
to make 3 500 let's say a night on their
space
or whatever so then that's the at the
second year i was probably like 23 24
years old when i did that
so then when the person got me the car
and the apartment and everything i was
like 27 but our relationship was already
like
dying off we were like friends but you
know what i mean until this day he pays
for it so does it make it different
that i helped him become more
established or
get into a space where those bills are
able to be paid off
because i helped him get there even
though we're no longer together
that way when you say it that way it is
different because now he feels entitled
there's the entitlement now
he feels entitled that he owes you just
like you how did you help him get there
if you if you were in this relationship
and you owe him so much when you got
your first big check you're gonna give
him some money because you're like thank
you yeah great that's what he's doing
for you right he's saying
help thank you for helping set me up
without this i wouldn't have this
and for that i don't care that you're
dating somebody else i just want to make
sure you straight
i want to make sure you're okay that is
a different narrative yeah yeah so
that's like the full story from that man
he's not hurt he's not he's not here
yeah yeah
[Music]
i'm like indifferent on that it's like
tough it's like yo i want to have fun
i'm a guy i said oh you bring it in
i'm a dude you're bringing another chick
when i have fun but i think in my
opinion it waters down our union a
little bit
because you want to go dip off and have
fun i would say maybe that can be a once
in a while thing but then it becomes too
consistent and too constant
it kind of waters it down and it might
be something fun without me knowing
after a while i might be
i kind of exit out of the situation that
they're doing their own thing without me
getting that phone call
you know what happens so what's like a
union type thing it can get sloppy you
can get messages i'm saying like when
your girl mentions the world girlfriend
like she's trying to bring a girl into
like to be serious that's a red flag
it's such a weird lifestyle i
i don't know anyone that lives like this
who who truly love you have another love
for a whole nother person
laying it down and how much you're
coming through bringing the food in
you know feeding both of them and
shouting them with gifts that female
bond will always win
so are you at work are you not there a
buster move
they in the house chilling doing girl
[ __ ] and you will lose that battle
so your girl asks you for another
girlfriend to date with y'all
that's a red flag she wants [ __ ]
oh so weird
i've been in a relationship with a guy
and um i'm bisexual so i like women too
and this particular female made me feel
almost close to how my man feel made me
feel emotionally at least
sometimes better sexually sometimes and
i express this to him
that let's have a girlfriend i brought
the girlfriend
and when it comes to lesbian sex this is
totally different
it's totally different
whatever it is it's warm with me and a
woman
it's more about enjoying her body
enjoying our conversation
enjoying those things it's really not
about penetration with a man he's like
trying to stick it in
he's like i gotta stick it in to get
please to release this stress
to whatever i gotta stick it in where
for us we can do all those things
without any penetration you understand
what i'm saying
just the way she touched me the way she
kissed me the way
our conversations sleeping next to her
those things so
introducing that into the relationship
he was like okay what man doesn't want
to woman women
until he's seen how she would look at me
yeah until he seen
uh slide things she would say like i
really like well that's what
like i some guys don't think it's
cheating if it's with a girl but i
genuinely don't think there's a
difference if you step by it you step
out
one day he called us on the phone with
each other and heard both of us telling
how much we love each other
he was so hurt and i couldn't understand
i'm like what man doesn't want to
[ __ ] with two [ __ ] he broke it down
to me and says
i was cool with us having fun with her
the moment you wanted her to be a part
of our relationship i have a problem
because there's no way you can be in
love with two people
at the same time and two there's no way
i'm doing all that i'm doing and i'm
gonna listen to you tell another woman
you feel the same way about her
that you feel about me it's just weird
it's disrespectful it speaks volumes to
what you think about our relationship i
didn't understand it for a long time
i'm still partially still trying to
understand it because it's like
well why can't we all just be happy
together to him he's feeling like he's
not getting 100 of me if i continue to
date this woman i would say
it's teach his own i'm not i'm not i'm
not bisexual so
i genuinely don't feel like long-term
yeah i'm not going to say never but i
would say it's a very rare long term to
find somebody
to have like three people in a marriage
because it's already hard enough to have
two people get along can you imagine
three
and i feel like the more people in a
relationship the harder it is
when i did introduce my ex to another
woman
you know in our situation when we went
away to miami for his birthday he found
it weird
i didn't want to participate i i just
wanted to see because i'm into voyeurism
so i like to watch
so i just wanted to see his reaction how
he would feel with another woman doing
certain things to him
he did not like that at all and i think
it's just an eagle thing that is weird
okay
um i think a lot of guys that are simps
make women entitled
and so obviously
this woman like thinks she's entitled to
rent um
from the guy you can't even say she's
wrong because she's getting it
so a lot of guys have hate for like
women and like their high standards but
you have to realize that men are the
ones
pushing the high standards so let me
know in the comments if you guys agree
or disagree don't forget to subscribe to
the channel i'll talk to you guys next
time